cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I want to clarify the
definition right yeah yeah God to me is
the literal definition of God a higher
powerful being Beyond us and our
capabilities the creator of all things
they don't have that they have a
something that they serve but but they
don't they they do not have that Concept
in their minds of a higher power it does
not exist they're worshiping but I I
it's it's not the same thing there is a
there is a plus one a negative one these
people are either blind and ignorant and
will just be party to the collective
unwittingly and useful idiots or they
they believe they are simply but a wet
robot and there is no truth but power so
they will wield it however they see fit
you you you ask these people for the
most part they will tell you there's no
God and nothing matters and then you
have many people who might say they
believe in God but are ignorant and the
banality of evil they are the
commonplace ignorant person who does not
want to know does not care to know but
will gladly March behind whatever they
think is safe that might be that might
be the case but they have a hierarchy as
Jordan Peterson would say a hierarchy of
values something has to be at the top
that something is going to be served
that something is going to have other
subordinate values but there isn't one
but there is what is it well it depends
right is it Gaia is it the Earth is it
the Earth that needs your sacrifices
because otherwise we're going to burn it
to death and therefore we need to like
go to zero emissions and then all of the
poor people across the globe need to die
because we're serving Gaia but now
you're talking about uh you're talking
about an infinite group of infinite
different groups of people yes everybody
has something that they are worshiping
and serving and I think that for a lot
of people it's sexual freedom and like I
have the right to do whatever I want
regardless of who it hurts I mean if if
sex your feelings your identity your
decisions if that's god well then we see
children end up being the sacrifice for
that some things get something you're
going to serve something everybody's
serving something and even the people
that are just going along why are they
going along because you're made to be
part of a community and that also is
what religion does for you right it
gives you a fellowship it gives you
community it gives you identity and so
these people are finding a God to
worship it's just destructive you know
and it often involves humans I just I
just again want to clarify the
definition there is a God and they are
not there lacking one so so you can say
that they have uh they have vestiges or
tenets but they do not have God they
have a lowercase G
they have a frame they have they it's
not even fair to say that they have a
framework they have a a caetic mass
that's all it is there there's there's
no cohesion to the ideology they've
bounced around from pro-war to anti-war
they they at first it was critical race
Theory then critical gender Theory there
is no nothing you can pin their ideology
too because there is not one I've had
this argument with you know people like
James Lindsay like they're they're not
marxists they will support capitalism if
capitalism is part of the tri part of
their tribal nature there's no logic or
moral framework to anything they do and
I think it's probably because they are
Godless and so their God is their self
that's it right and if your God is
yourself that means you get to bend and
you get to change right that's it and
this is the ultimate original sin and I
mean I'm talking to you as if um
my husband's a pastor right I carry my
my Bible's right here I read it with
everybody that I'm with so I love God I
know God but I also know
The Substitute which is very very often
and what the enemy will try to sell you
is you are your own God and that is why
you can and like this this is my point
is is they don't like themselves and
there's there is there is no nucleus to
which they have adhered to so in order
for there to be a God that they worship
there would need to be a centralized
structure which there is not that well
so that is why I love yeah that is why
people that worship self are as Hannah
was saying before the show
more likely to be depressed you know the
ones that are being sucked into you know
all of the different maladies the social
maladies yeah I think there is a culture
within the United States and I think
globally too that says you know
ultimately your own needs and your own
desires are what should govern your
whole life and if you are completely
absorbing I mean there are narcissists
who have very low self-esteem right so
they hate themselves but they also are
completely obsessed with their worldview
and they cannot be proven wrong about
anything they have all the traits of
classic narcissism but also you wouldn't
know it because they're covert
narcissists they seem like they are uh
defeatist in some way and I think it's
true that there are so many people who
are lacking direction or meaning in
their life that they either turn inwards
and become obsessed with their own being
and validating their own feelings or
they look to be the Defenders of
something and so you'll get people who
say well I'm here advocating for people
who can't Advocate themselves I'm here
defending you know uh people who are
gender fluid and I've got to be an ally
and this that and the other they are
looking to represent something because
they are so lost in and of themselves
well that's part of what it means to be
human is you are called to something
greater and if you're not serving the
greatest thing you will find something
lesser to serve I I have a I have a you
know I thought it was a good question
you asked about the video game Trope why
can't why is it so hard for someone to
be evil I wonder if that's we should
actually do an experiment with that
actually test people and try and figure
out oh yeah especially as video games
are more realistic when you're in a
first person game and you can actually
feel the knife going into the thing and
you can hear the screen stop how do you
feel that nice haptic feedback gloves
that will vibrate and create pressure
when you do things in the VR haptic
feedback there's also there's also uh
controllers technology the controllers
have pressure resistance now so when you
are like pushing a door open in a video
game and this is much more rudimentary
are you in an entire suit no well you
could be yeah so we actually have the
full VR thing downstairs not set up yet
where you can actually stand and run in
place but in some video games they'll be
like a door the door's closed to open it
you have to hold down R2 which is the
back trigger button on the controller
and it actually resists your push
whereas normally it just presses very
easily the controller can actually
create resistance to make you have to
give put more strength into it so with
haptics uh I don't know about putting a
knife into something but it can it can
squeeze your hand and vibrate and create
Sensations yeah but nobody that's not
common no it's going to become more
common in these action games where it's
so realistic that you're actually it's
gonna feel and seem like you're killing
something for real like the pig will be
screaming and blood will be coming and
you'll be like having to step and that
will create psychopathy in human if they
have to if that's how they train their
their gaming is like they're killing
stuff for real like that's not I read a
threat read on Reddit the other day from
someone who made a villain character in
Baldur's Gate and it was a really cool
looking character like glowing red eyes
and like a crazy face paint and they
were like I got halfway through and like
every time I'm faced with these these
challenges it's like I'm just doing
things I really really don't like and
don't want to play the game like I can't
do it but the game is CR is created as
such that you can do the villain stuff
or do the good guy stuff or be the Rogue
or whatever and they're people like I
just can't bring myself to do it
I would love to do a test where you sit
people down and and make them give them
like a scene from one of these games
easily scripted with you know Oblivion
Skyrim or something or even Baldur's
Gate and then actually ask people their
background their age their income their
education level all of that stuff their
voting patterns I would love to see
voting patterns maybe we should do this
what do you think you would see I'm
curious I think you'd find Democrats
overwhelmingly being okay with uh you
know like let's I I think you would see
you would have there would be a tendency
among people who say they vote Democrat
with being okay with a bad thing
happening in the game to Sir to varying
degrees why do you think that is based
on the political world that we see right
now when I ask someone why is Joe Biggs
going to prison for two decades and they
literally say I don't care and I'm like
a human being is being imprisoned by an
oppressive state to destroy His Life For
What and they're like so what like
that's evil yeah
that is evil is it a form of nihilism I
no it's evil it doesn't matter but if
they're like it doesn't matter that Joe
Big's got 22 years like is that another
aspect of nihilism yeah it matters right
it's it's utilitarian thinking versus
deontological thinking and
utilitarianism in my view has a tendency
towards evil there are certain
circumstances where you can say we're
faced with a difficult decision and we
are going to try and maximize
life-saving there's not much you can do
you've got two school buses about to go
over the edge of a cliff one's got a 10
kids in it one's got three kids
man you gotta go for the bus the 10 kids
and to save as many people as you want
you can't make decisions on the
individuals of the other bus and this
This lends itself to the trolley problem
but to go back to uh Joe Biggs
individually it's deontological morality
you cannot take immoral actions against
an individual it matters more than
anything that when it comes to Enrique
when it comes to Joe Biggs and the other
proud boys that have been overly
sentenced and the other j6ers it matters
the world that each of these individuals
receive proper Justice and the sentences
they got are completely improper the
fact that we see Democrats celebrating
the torture and unjust rulings shows me
the evil rests more so not absolutely
so if we were to create a video game
scenario where your character uh sees a
man holding a cat and then the guy
instructs you to kill the cat I I'd be
willing to bet that it would skew to a
certain degree probably a small degree
that Democrats are like so what do it
and Republicans would be more likely not
I can't believe yeah I I do think that
it would be different if it was I mean
because like I don't know the the people
that lean left in my life uh they don't
have kids they have pets so I think that
they might have a hard time killing them
not they'd be like oh it's a video game
who cares I wonder if that's right
Associated from like and they'd say who
cares it doesn't matter if it's if it's
less about political affiliation more
about nihilism uh versus Heaven because
something I'm not having kids it's like
well what is there to live for really
what's the purpose and everyone says
let's see having kids how about how
about this we get a thousand
conservatives a thousand Libertarians a
thousand liberals a thousand
Independents and then you know to what
degree we can get communist socialists
you know fascists whatever and uh
you make a maybe 300 of each encounter a
different scenario a republican is shown
a video a video game scenario where a
Democrat is holding a republican by you
know on his knees with a weapon and
instructs you to commit and act against
them
in the video game it's just a video game
it's not real life you're fine
then 300 Republicans are presented a
scenario where it's the Democrat on the
ground then where it's an independent on
the ground and then you see are they
more or less willing to commit are these
groups uh based on the political
affiliation of the characters in the
game the answer
I think this is a great uh Research
Institute to start for Tim Cass
University and
imagine a scenario in a video game where
and I quite literally mean a video game
like Skyrim and you have the villain
let's say he's a demon quite literally a
demonic figure with Big Red Wings and
he's a man on his knees wearing a Maga
hat and it's like he's wearing Knight
armor and as a sword who's wearing a
trumpet would the Democrat voter
be inclined to serve the devil master in
the game I was gonna say it's sad to
think that someone will be more likely
to attack someone based or let someone
suffer based on their clothing but then
I was thinking about military uniforms
and I mean that's the whole purpose of
uniforms who to make suffering and there
were I think in like in one year alone
there were 800 instances where Trump
supporters were physically attacked on
the streets at random like at what point
does civilian clothing become a military
insignia a militant symbol I don't think
of it as a militant symbol I think there
there was this study that uh Teen Vogue
I think commissioned they published
about this week
um saying that the overwhelming majority
of men and women they asked them about
their red flags and green flags and
dating yeah so you wrote about that I
did write about them
thank you so much uh so what I find
interesting about this is because it was
mostly large it was largely framed off
of political stuff so uh the
overwhelming majority of both men and
women said if someone identified as a
MAG or republican that would be a red
flag but but men said Communists men
were more likely to lean towards
Communists still 55 of women also said
it would be red so your Comics but men
fewer men thought uh someone identifying
as a liberal was a red flag than the men
that thought someone who believes in
astrology was a red flag I mean there
are limits to the political affiliations
and I think there are like I'm just
saying look wait hold on I say to your
point it is interesting to me that
it was they were willing to forgive
liberals more than they were willing to
forgive imagine service the way people
perceive your political creation does I
think impact how they these were red
flags it didn't say they would not date
it did not say they had disdain it said
it was a red flag that's it and I don't
care who the guy is if there is a
beautiful woman and she's got a
communist flag pin he knows he can
change her political Affiliates no he
doesn't care about changing but deep
down he knows he can change he's just
like yeah the woman may see the guy with
the Maga symbol and be like I can change
him for sure but more importantly
anyone I gotta be completely honest guys
especially Trump supporters out there yo
if I'm not in the dating Market but I
just have to say like if I met a woman
and her whole identity was like I'm a
Maga Republican I'd be like that's kind
of like anybody that I think it's gonna
be super weird yeah and even if yours
are Trump supporter just being like that
would be like Oh and it works the other
way too like more women were more likely
to think it was a green flag if you were
saying if you said black lives matter
right like but why why does that matter
in who you're dating well because
they're looking for political compliance
in a way that they find to be acceptable
women were more likely to want they
would value talking about politics more
than men did Men actually didn't care
about how often you talk about the
majority of men don't care about how
frequently you talk about politics uh
men were more likely to think it was a
red flag or a green flag if women drank
cow's milk over any kind of non-dairy
milk like women were not thinking about
this at all but people are about
especially based on gender they're
evaluating your uh political and and
cultural behaviors in these sort of
small ways and it gives you an insight
into what you're doing so I think this
study on video games actually really
fascinating I think it could be
interesting to see if people were more
willing to hurt people uh based on
political ideology even if it is in a
video game if there and you'd have to
find a way to like test out okay
I'm so curious and hopefully you guys
well you probably have already seen it
but let me ask you each uh how often do
you guys think about the Roman Empire
fairly often how many times I mean per
week per day where are you at three
times a week minimum yeah oh man yeah
just probably I mean we talk about it on
the show and I see clips of it and stuff
which remind me so I don't know if that
counts yeah plus like how many times
does it come to mind is my question the
chosen keeps popping up on my TV
sometimes I'll watch like outside
literally all the time okay if I watched
something for two hours straight does
this just kind of thinking of it once
because I think about it for two hours
constantly so have you seen this The
Tick Tock where the woman is like oh my
God my husband thinks about the Roman
Empire like once a day yeah and I mean
like
oh I was thinking about the Roman Empire
earlier actually so maybe it's more than
two times a week yeah I I was I was
watching a show earlier and it auto like
this is not me choosing to think about
it but the chosen came on and there's
romance
there's that joke that uh uh in a
certain age men have to decide if
they're gonna get really into grilling
or World War II history oh my god there
are things that men I that that's not a
question I was no no it's not even my I
texted my husband I'm like do you ever
think about the Roman Empire how often
he's like no about once a day yeah my
dad and older brother referenced the
Roman Empire my entire life growing up I
felt like number one I was not that
interested
yeah this is correct women women are
shocked to find this out uh so as much
as many women don't like fresh and fit
uh are you familiar with Russian fit I
listen to your cultural War episode with
my 16 year old on a road trip so we have
lots of lots to talk about yeah that's
actually how that's how we parent we
listen to it and we discuss they
mentioned women don't have hobbies
and it's like it's a shocking thing to
men to discover and I was like in your
little uh this is something about you so
uh they said that when they bring women
on their show
and they say it's average woman but I
really do think it's like it's Miami
local women so they're they're choosing
from a select batch but they say when
they ask women like what do you do for
fun they go what do you mean and he's
like what do you do for fun like what do
you do and they're like I I don't know
like I hang out with my friends it's
like yeah but like doing what like we go
out like but what go out what does that
mean where do you go and like what do
you mean what do we do we just go out
what are you talking about like the
women are confused by the question well
so men and women are different okay and
this is the difference women form
relationships face to face men form
relationships side by side so it really
is a it's a different thing men form
bonds doing things together like going
to war and playing on Sports and
building a shed women don't need to do
that Hannah and I sat down before him
were like just tell me about your life
yeah oh my God where did you go you you
reference uh Men Are from Marvel from
Venus when uh when John Gray wrote that
one of my favorite things that I read in
it by the way my dad kept recommending
that to me uh because he was like you
just need to know that they're not the
same thing but one of my favorite
observations like gray had was that men
go to lunch to talk about something they
go to lunch to be like we've got an
issue we got to talk about this we're
going to make business deal and women
will go to lunch to gather information
right it's a reason that like I have
multiple female friends I can be on the
phone multiple times a week for four
hours because there's just stuff to talk
about man there's yeah but it's people
versus things it's very different
subjects that's right chemical bonding
has these elements too like ionic
bonding where you guys would be
interacting sharing an electron bouncing
it back and forth or covalent bond where
you're sharing it together then there's
metallic bonding where all the electrons
are headed in one direction we're all
protons witnessing it that's like the
male communication tactic is a metallic
type of bond we're all focused on it
together it's uh it's object versus
subject so yeah the meme is that when
women take pictures of objects it's a
picture of themself next to the object
man will take a picture of the object so
uh this is this popped up on Reddit
because a guy would be like hey just got
a new video game and it's a picture of
the game and women would be like look at
the game I got it's them going like this
holding it is it better to say instead
of that men communicate metallically
women do it ionically or however you
were saying earlier is it better to say
that the masculine forms so yeah the
masculine form of communication is
focusing on a thing the feminine because
it's not all always women that do the
feminine Behavior sometimes men are
feminine and women are masculine or they
embody we each embody both yeah so
because I do enjoy the the cross
communication you were saying women
generally do I do it a lot more than
normal let me just give you a Family Guy
reference when Peter goes to it he goes
to a clinic to get like medical tests on
him to make money or something I can't
remember the exact reason and they're
like we're gonna give you the squirrel
Gene and then it like he turns into no
squirrel and they're like we're gonna
give you the Seth Rogen Gene that makes
you seemingly funny even though you're
not saying anything that's funny and
then finally they give him the gay gene
so Peter becomes gay and then he calls I
think he calls Quagmire or or Joe or
something and he's like what what you
doing and they're like what do you mean
you called me and he's like what you
thinking about what what are you calling
me for yeah like like for guys it's just
like what no why are you asking me these
questions the one I see on on Instagram
all the time is uh girls like husband's
pretending to call wisely like the way
they want them to and it's just like hey
it's just on my lunch break like what
are you doing
oh my gosh did you ask Andrea about
whatever and it's the same the opposite
is girls will like it's infuriating to
women that if you have like a boyfriend
who goes on you know to golf with all
his friends and then you're like oh how
was it they're like it's great you know
how is how's uh Joe doing with Andrea I
heard that they were going through some
rough times he's like I don't know oh
they broke up I'm like what when I don't
know they have no details for you this
is what women live for but it's because
we serve different purposes in society
so our communication obviously is
different we're hardwired to seek out
different information that's why it's
good to have both people on the team
right yeah having different
conversations or Mom and a dead when
you're a kid
you get 1 000 then before us points good
job
how do we credit these points oh I I
just keep track okay that's okay that's
great it's like it's like Hogwarts yeah
you don't need to understand oh okay
it's your honorary degrees Yeah no I'll
give you whatever you need to just keep
cranking out these content wisdom you
know and I beat beat Ian it is I win but
Tim cast university has a house cub it's
very complicated you'll have to hear
about it in our Research Institute okay
uh but I do think that there is
something really valuable to
acknowledging that men and women's
communication is different but that
doesn't have to be bad it just is one of
the reasons that I think monogamy is
great because you only have to figure
one woman or one man out yeah right you
don't have to figure all of them out and
get good at communicating with them and
learn to change your Communication in a
way that isn't emotionally satisfactory
you just have to figure out one person
and there's these there's these General
distinctions that are generally true and
then every husband and wife is going to
break the mold in some way so like I I
am very low emotion and it's actually
really sabotaged to my husband in a lot
of ways because he's a pastor and that's
a high shepherding High Counseling and
he's very very good at it but you know I
I'm like honey just give me the
information what do you need just get
right to it you know I don't have a lot
of time I'm gonna be here for another
five minutes we can have this
conversation I'm gonna continue roasting
these brussels sprouts okay but I just
need to just get this to me really fast
um and then he'll go to work or go to
church or he'll talk to somebody and
he'll go why did you choose this color
for the bulletin and the woman would be
like
yeah and so it's like I have I I'm so
kind of low emotional needs uh and and
generally women aren't they need a
little more hand-holding they need a
little more like building up and um so
he has had to unlearn some of what I've
taught him but yeah like we don't fit
into a mold there are personality
differences but there are also
generalities that tend to hold true do
you well women are communists and men
are capitalists oh okay yeah uh
Tendencies right so if you look at the
voting patterns I'm being hyperbolic to
a certain degree when you look at voting
patterns women over a monthly vote
Democrat if you look at a map of the
United States If Only Women voted it's
every State's blue except for one but
isn't that single women yes right yeah
okay and then if you look at uh only
male voters it's every state is red but
one the question about women voting
Republican is are women who vote
Republican more likely to get married or
are women who get married later more
likely to vote Republicans right so we
know that there's a correlation we don't
know if it's conservative women who have
more children because really it's not
marriage it's child rearing right women
that have more children tend to be
conservative or does having more
children make you conservative and I
understand the kind of communist
socialist thing because the only place
that socialism really is effective and
natural is in the family right that
really small scale yeah personal and
five yeah like unconditional commitment
you know you you do what you can those
that are have less still have their
needs met all of that kind of thing that
is where it needs to take place so I
understand that women being a little
more nurturing
social family-oriented others oriented
because we are uh that that would make
sense because then they take their
little like micro society and apply it
to the whole nation yeah I've found
maybe you guys can confirm or deny as
females that generally uh the feminine
uh when if a woman complains she just
wants you to listen and understand
whereas if a man complains he wants a
solution to the problem yep I don't know
if that's it's not always every time but
I'm wondering if you guys agree with
that because I found it excessively
successful in my relationships I think
it's a good place to start uh I will say
again that in my relationship with my
husband be I would say literally because
he's a good man he is intuitive and he
is uh very in touch with what's going on
emotionally with me and my kids and so
he is more long-suffering when it comes
to listening and maybe because I'm
really really busy I don't have time for
the deep emotional rabbit trails that we
go down so I don't know if it's it's
just personality or if it's kind of
stage we are in life I'm so busy uh that
I don't have time for the deep emotional
dive and I I personally don't need it
but if you're a guy I would recommend
defaulting with yeah just listen to her
yeah and then maybe ask do you want a
solution or do you just want me to hear
you out did you guys
involve therapy raising four kids
instead of like was there ever like
external therapists and stuff that you
guys go to as a family or individuals
that helped you no well we did do some a
deep a deep marriage counseling about
four years ago like you know most
marriages go through a rough spot and we
did we had like a year or two where we I
felt more like enemies than friends you
just have to push through that kind of
stuff so we did have to do a very
intense marriage week of therapy to like
do our realignment but largely it's been
fine uh it's been great largely it's
been great between us and between our
kids uh in terms of therapy not therapy
but you've got to read good information
you've got to find other people that are
parenting well that are a few steps
ahead of you because you need that on
the ground Intel what did you do for
this when your kid acted this way what
when how did you talk with them about
this one I mean there are things that
you are not going to know unless you see
somebody else do it successfully and
glean their wisdom so you don't have to
reinvent the wheel how'd you find those
people at church go to church I'm not
kidding no I don't care I'm laughing
because it's why we had church for so
long correct whether you're registered
or not it's where people come together
and your community shares resources
knowledge information values and it's
been shattered that's right I know we
say that in our book uh you know our
raising conservative kids in a woke City
the entire last chapter is called find
your people like you might think that
you are the only conservative in Austin
or Chicago but you're not there are
other people that share your values
there at church and you know what I
don't care if you disbelieve that a guy
can live for 72 hours in a whale's
digestive tract I I it maybe you're
skeptical but do you want other people
that are going to fortify you and your
children and tell them that they are not
crazy for choosing not to wear the mask
with a little cutout for your French
horn go to church that is where you're
going to find those people so even if
you don't believe that the Bible is the
Divine inspired word of God you need the
people that are at church go there don't
go to a church with a female Pastor go
to a real Church how come what's the
problem with female pastors how much
time do you have we've got like three
minutes before we go to super chess what
well then let's just get this over with
uh
my next book that I'm going to co-author
with my husband is called headship and
it's why God designed there to be
headship that is not domination control
or chauvinism it's headship it's
leadership it's primary responsibility
in two institutions and it's not
government and it's not Academia and
it's not business it is the home and it
is the church men are supposed to be the
heads of those two institutions why is
that because those are the two
institutions responsible for human
formation and men are not optional in
the project of human formation and when
men are made optional they leave both
the home and the church and that's what
we've been doing thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time